- People would not be happy
if I didn't ask you about Pitch Perfect.
Are y'all gonna make another one?
They're so good.
- Yeah, we.
- [Kelly Clarkson] I love
that you say you can't sing
and you sing like so well, by the way.
- You sing too?
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- Yes.
- Well.
- I've seen you. I've seen you.
- Yes.
(crowd cheers)
- I sing, but I don't sing, like you.
I mean,
- Oh, please.
- Like I can sing to
my dog, you know well.
- Please sing a note?
- She sings on the, yes go, let's do it.
- Okay what thing?
- She said, "No, what?"
- Let's sing.
What's the line?
- A line.
- Yeah, we just need one.
I don't the one line between the three.
We sing it together.
What's the line.
- Oh, like a verse.
- Yeah, like a verse.
Yeah, that one.
- Okay. Are we going hymn?
Are we going like Amazing Grace?
What are we doing here?
- Okay.
- Oh my God,
this is a nightmare.
(crowd laughs)
Oh my God.
I'm singing with Kelly Clarkson.
Like, this is my nightmare.
- Wait somebody else start.
'Cause I'm a soprano.
So I wanna start low enough.
I don't know where your ranges are.
- I have a pitch,
♪ Ahh ♪
- you know, you can't.
♪ Amazing grace ♪
- See, you sound right.
_ Yeah, I agree.
- No, it was bad.
- What?
- It was bad.
- No it wasn't.
You just said you have
a problem with pitch.
(crowd claps)
I gotta be honest with you.
- It's because,
you were over there.
- I gotta be honest with you
I was like, she is bold
if she has a problem with pitch.
(lady laughs)
She's like, let's sing.
And I was like,
this is not gonna go well.
- I'm not gonna go off pitch ever.
- No, you have great pitch.
It was right on pitch.
- I hope she's listening.
(Kelly laughs)
- I love that.
That's never happened impromptu.
I love how much she's sweating right now.
(crowd laughs)
She was like, "She said, what?"